the crater economy is booming billions
of videos massive brand deals
multi-millionaire influencers it's a
hundred billion dollar economy that
didn't exist 20 years ago so how did the
creator profession grow so incredibly
fast it all comes down to money
let's go back to 2007. YouTube had just
sold to Google and broke into pop
culture some YouTubers had millions of
views and Google was ready to turn that
into a commercial business but many
viewers weren't ready for commercials in
fact YouTube creators chose not to run
money making ads on their videos because
fans hated them so much at that time of
YouTube there was no such thing as an ad
Revenue split there weren't such things
as ads on YouTube it was a totally
ad-free website and they basically
explained you know what would happen
there'd be like a REV split there was no
such thing as like a pre-roll or a
mid-roll or a post role it was just a
little pop-up at the bottom and at that
time we were a little bit worried that
our fan base would call us sellouts for
having an ad pop up on the bottom of the
video and they did I still had my
part-time job at Chuck E cheese and I
was going to community college and
living in my parents house we were
getting some crazy views on videos but
at that time it was just like okay this
is cool and there's something here but
there's no money here yet
but years later after some trial and
error YouTube's online economy picked up
pace the company said it's business
model apart from traditional TV by
leaning on the commercial appeal of its
Stars millions of channels started
making money last year YouTube made more
than 28 billion dollars in advertising
and had 2 million creators in its ads
program but unlike in 2007 YouTube has
some serious competitors
foreign
has emerged as a defining app of a
generation the short form video platform
loved by gen Z was the most downloaded
app of 2021 and has surged to a billion
plus global users I know for sure
there's more money going into Tick Tock
than there was two years ago a lot of
advertisers want to go wherever the
teens are it is like the hot thing and
advertisers want to be associated with
the hot thing Tick Tock just exploded so
much with YouTube there was a Creator
Community like there weren't a very
large amount of creators that had over a
million subscribers in like
2010. with Tick Tock it's like how many
creators have over a million like
everybody and their Grandma it's wild
the growth on that platform is insane
it's the first platform since YouTube to
pay creators in a meaningful way but
tick tock's approach isn't without
critics Tick Tock is a whole different
game and because it's so new on the
scene it's a little bit harder to figure
out I've been on Tech talk for two years
now and I actually haven't had the
opportunity to monetize on Tick Tock as
a Creator even though I'm one of the
bigger creators on Tick Tock they choose
the people that they want to add on to
that program and they monetize that way
but there is a big pool of money that
they have where they can give that to
each Creator so whether you create a
certain amount of content or not that
amount that you're able to receive from
Tick Tock is fixed you aren't able to
continue to create more content and earn
more and more and more I've kind of been
treading lightly and using it more as a
platform to grow my audience and even
redirect my audience to my other
platforms or my products because the
platforms they could be here one day and
go on the next they could be having this
amazing monetization model and then the
next day it's gone so it's really
important for creators to take that into
consideration and to take the influence
that they have and move it into
somewhere that they can control as well
the Creator economy has taken off in
just a couple of decades and it
certainly has staying power but online
Fame can still be fleeting creators will
need to adapt to platforms if they want
to translate Newfound stardom into
lasting careers
[Music]
thank you
[Music]